foreign
[Music]
thank you for sitting down with Forbes
for the 50 over 50. oh it's my honor to
be here thank you I think it's our honor
to speak with you you have a bevy of
superlatives I'm going to read a few
you've been called America's most
experienced astronaut you have
675 days in space
you are just back from your fourth
flight in orbit you are the first woman
to command the International Space
Station and just recently just this year
you became the first woman to command a
private space flight
did I miss any
well there are a few others but it's
okay what do this
I guess to start broad what do those
titles mean to you what do those
superlatives mean to you
um well I mean it's all an honor it's a
part of being a very large team you
don't do space flight as an individual
but it's been a phenomenal experience
with the opportunities that NASA gave me
and now with Axiom space to be able to
continue is even more exciting
we'll get to what you're doing right now
but just to rewind you grew up in Iowa
and I understand you were inspired by
Apollo 11 and Neil Armstrong's walk on
the moon but also NASA's first
commissioning of the first female
astronauts in 1978 was a seminal moment
to you which of those moments
proved more inspirational and set you on
the path that you were on that's a great
question because it was the inspiration
was definitely the guys walking on the
moon but the when it became a goal in my
mind as opposed to Just a Dream
was when they selected the first female
astronauts it made me think I could do
this too and I was interested in biology
and chemistry and one of the astronauts
female astronauts Shannon Lucid was a
biochemist and there were two medical
doctors and I was in interested in life
sciences and so I thought this this is
real I could I could do this luckily I
had no idea how difficult it might be
and how the diverse the selection
process is so I applied after I got my
PhD I started applying and uh it was 10
years before I was finally selected as
an astronaut and it was funny you know
looking back now I can say it was those
10 years that made me qualified to have
the experiences and be ready to be
selected as the first female commander
of the ISS to be selected as the first
female and
non-military chief of the astronaut
office all of these things were because
of the teamwork the leadership
experiences that I gained during those
10 years of not being selected at the
time of course I was disappointed every
time I was rejected and of course I was
like I need to be an astronaut now but
in retrospect I can say say those were
the best 10 years of preparing me I
think a common question for astronauts
is how did you get there so what were
the steps you took in those 10 years you
get your PhD in Biochemistry and then
you have 10 years of rejection so to
speak but the rejection was learning
what did you learn so I um I was working
at Nasa already
immediately after I finished my PhD I
did a postdoctoral fellowship at Nasa
and then began working for one of the
contractors and then eventually for NASA
for the government but it was uh during
those 10 years that I was became the
lead negotiator in the U.S Russian
medical operations program medical
Sciences program that we were doing
together
and I was working in Russia we didn't
have supplies there we had to come up
with processes and procedures of how to
do everything working with a small group
of people and it was just a a great
experience uh for me as a leader to
learn all these lessons some good some
bad and but to be successful in the end
and to take away those those team
leadership experiences that prepared me
to be ready later on so that first
flight to space was 2002 that's correct
it was a six-month Mission so you've
never been before and you go up to space
and you know you're going not just for a
few days or a quick little orbit it's
six months well it was planned to be
four and it got extended to six four
months is still a long time how do you
put hair you have spent that was just
the
your most recent was just 10 days but
what's your longest nine and a half
months how do you prepare for something
like that
well
um we do a lot of training which is
great that that's what helps me feel
ready and prepared for situations makes
me feel prepared to go
it takes years to do all that training
we train all over the world in the
different countries that have different
scientific modules on board the space
station and learn everybody's systems
and then of course I trained in Russia
because I launched twice on a Russian
vehicle and once on a shuttle and then
this last time on a SpaceX Dragon
capsule so I've I've Had A diversity of
different spacecraft to learn about and
it's been a lot of fun and and exciting
to learn all the nuances and differences
between those vehicles
but the training is the part part of the
process that prepares us for those
missions long duration missions in
general you have to be very much Adept
at doing whatever you're assigned to do
because in a nine and a half month
mission for instance you don't know what
you're going to need to know how to do
so it's a lot of what we call
skills-based training where I know
generic skills I can do maintenance on
lots of different things and then when
I'm assigned to a specific task whether
it's maintenance or it's a science
experiment I have the general skills to
be successful
so you go up knowing you need these
skills but you don't quite know the
application until you get there and you
have to use your Ingenuity and
Innovation yeah on the on the spot you
have to be very adaptable and I I think
that's an important aspect of any
um successful organization is being
adaptable and and you know as a person
as an individual I think that
adaptability comes in extremely handy is
there a story of adaptability of a
moment on the space station that stands
out in your mind yeah there's a few but
one that comes to mind first is uh I was
when I was a commander of the
International Space Station my first
time I've been up there a month and a
shuttle arrived and the commander was
Pam melroy the first time we had two
female commanders of two different
spacecraft in orbit at the same time
but during that her short stay we had a
problem with a solar array as we
deployed it it tor and it required
we needed to fix it in order to either
fix it or jettison it and these arrays
are 115 feet long and jettising in it
would mean that we wouldn't have enough
power to add additional modules that
were coming up in the next month or so
and so we we were it was very high
pressure moment you know trying to
figure out how are we going to fix this
we of course we had a phenomenal ground
team that was helping us figure it all
out but on orbit then we had to come up
with the design solution which was to
make cufflinks out of you know several
feet long pieces of wire and special
clamps and cutting metal and punching
holes in the metal and in space you have
to worry about all the metal shavings
and everything because you don't want to
get in in your eyes so you had vacuum
cleaners out and shaving and so you know
hand constructing something because you
can't just go to the you know Lowe's or
the Home Depot yeah to make it yourself
and so but I I think every step of the
way was really pretty Innovative because
a young engineer came in and said how
about we just span the tear because it
was like a five or six foot long tear
how about we just span it with these
cufflinks wow and because there were
some integral holes in the solar array
and just span it so that as we continue
to extend the solar array it wouldn't
tear and make that Gap bigger
and that's incredible it was it was a
very simple elegant Innovative solution
to a very difficult problem that would
have cost us a lot you know potentially
the further expansion of the entire
International Space Station if we hadn't
gotten that array deployed
as a biochemist and a scientist by
training what do you see as the science
that we can do in space in a
microgravity setting as you call it not
entirely anti-gravity what are you
looking to find when you go up there
well I think that I'm a life scientist
so I think my expertise is in that area
I am excited by the potentials offered
by developing new medicines and vaccines
and other things that can be used as
therapies here on the ground for
instance on the my last most recent
Mission we were looking at cancer cells
breast cancer colorectal and epithelial
cancer cells and looking at a particular
drug that we would use to try and treat
those Cancers and the reason we use zero
gravity is the cancers actually grow
faster there so any treatments that we
use on drugs have to work very well
otherwise you know the cancer growth
will overtake them
they also grow more like they do in your
human body on Earth the the cells are
flattened by gravity and don't grow like
they do in your body when you're testing
them and so this gives us a nice model
for testing medical Therapies in in that
particular instance we also have done
grown stem cells in space and these are
the cells that you can be used as
medical therapies potentially here on
the ground for various different
diseases but
interestingly we found that the cells
grow some types of stem cells actually
grow better in space
and so I think all of these are very
exciting there's
um you know applications of
we grow crystals protein crystals that
show us the structures of various
different like duchesne's muscular
dystrophy they've found they've been
able to
develop drugs because of a better
understanding of the molecular structure
of different aspects of different
diseases and so it's just exciting that
we could develop medical Therapies in
space and and that's just because I'm
more familiar with the life sciences
they there's lots of physical
experiments that we can be done as well
and I'm looking forward to Axiom station
as a commercial space station actually
using microgravity as a tool
let's talk a little more about that I
sat down with the CTO of Axiom and he
was talking about retinal implants and
how you can develop those on Earth but
they're little micro super micro
buckling that can happen and they're
still usable but then he described the
process of making these in an
anti-gravity or microgravity situation
and then how companies can develop and
then sell that technology on the ground
how far away are we from humans using
medicine or tools that have been
developed on the International Space
Station I I really think we're probably
less than five years away from actually
using them we've there's a vaccine
that's already in trials for salmonella
food poisoning and it was developed by
growing those particular bacteria in
space they are actually more virulent
and then so then the investigators
meeting they're more hazardous and then
the investigators here on the ground
then developed a vaccine using that that
microorganism
that was grown in space and so there's
lots of ways to use these tools of
things that we can grow or develop in
space but just to zoom out what does the
first commercial space station mean to
the broader public and how would you
describe axiom's mission to everyone
watch watching this video well axiom's
main mission is to expand access to
space uh and that is for individuals for
governments for scientists and um in
universities just expanding that access
getting more people opportunities in
space because it is an amazing
environment
for research or technology development
but also giving people the perspective
of where we are in this vast universe
and and what does that mean to us as a
as humanity and so expanding that access
has a lot of meanings for our world and
our planet
and I'm excited about it as a scientist
for all those technical uh
developments that that it will enable so
you had a long career at Nasa and you
technically retired from NASA in 2018.
at that time did you think you were done
you were going to sail off in the sunset
and relax I really didn't know if
commercial space was going to be
developed as quickly as it has and and
you know we hear about all the new
satellite companies and new rockets the
you know commercial access for cargo and
uh people and it's exciting it's this
really exciting time I just didn't know
if it would develop fast enough for me
to be able to rejoin uh in this new era
of development of commercial space so
I'm really excited about this
opportunity what made you want to come
to Axiom well they did offer a space
flight
but I as I mentioned before I was
actually interested in coming to the
Axiom and working with the scientists
and the development of a space station
that would optimize for future
development of
medical therapies and Technologies and
other capabilities so it's it's
um it's quite a pleasure to be working
with a team like this we have a lot of
experienced folks who worked on the
International Space Station and the
development of that and we have all
these young Innovative engineers and
it's so fun to watch the interaction and
for me I am evidently now a graybeard
but I'm able to go in and talk to these
young Engineers with these new ideas and
it's exciting because you know they'll
say how about this and I'm like oh
that's a phenomenal idea you know you
might want to tweak this because it
won't work quite as the same as you
anticipate here in zero gravity or you
know this one's not going to work in
zero gravity unless you change this X or
Y or Z and so it's fun for me to use
that experience that I have in space to
to help these new guys develop an even
better space station you're taking your
675 days in space and using that
knowledge to then fuel The Innovation
for the first commercial space station
that's and it's fun it's exciting to be
a part of that we're also developing a
new spacesuit that will be used for
Artemis 3 when NASA's astronauts walk on
the surface of the Moon
and so that's exciting too to be part of
developing a new space suit one that
fits better hopefully I was going to ask
what's the significance of that and we
heard about how there was one mission
that had to be delayed because the
spacesuits didn't fit the women who were
going to be on the mission so does this
new suit correct that error that's what
we're intending to do is to make it a
suit that will be adaptable for
all size ranges you recently returned
from a 10-day Mission with Axiom what
does your day-to-day with the company
look like when you're not in space
you're the director of human space
flight yes what does that mean so I'm
helping develop and modify the training
as we learn exactly what we need for our
mission we're modifying training and
operations products and so I can use my
expertise to modify the next phase for
the next mission the ax3 mission or
later missions but also for our space
station we're we're doing technology
demonstrations while we're on these
precursor missions that will enable us
to be ready when our station is launched
in 2025 or 2026. I think I hear
commercial space station and I assume
space tourism but how much of your work
is focused on getting regular people up
in space versus companies who can
develop products like the ones we were
talking about I mean we we really want
to diversify and have it be you know
everyone as much as possible
um you know on my mission the ax2
mission I had a private astronaut and
two government astronauts and and I
think we will see a mixture of both of
those in the future I I would also
anticipate that we would see
scientists astronauts that would be
going up to develop some technology or
test something for future
development on board the space station
you've previously said that through
Axiom you're changing the evolution of
the idea that Humanity belongs in space
what does that mean
for me it means
um space right now is kind of viewed as
an outpost and not a destination I'd
like it to see it as a destination space
is there we can use it as a tool we
might other people might have a station
that's for tourism and that they just a
hotel and this one is going to be a
space station where we're going to you
know develop Technologies and Science
and use that tool but also allow
additional access to countries and
people
to do experiments and work in this
environment you've also called space
your second home which seems like a
remarkable statement given how
inhospitable the climate is to life
typically without innovation no why do
you call it your second home having
spent so many days in space I think you
know is Pretty Natural to want to call
it home but I I really enjoy my pre you
know being there it
it's very special to feel that you can
adapt to a completely different
environment and and work there live
there and have this be normal
I remember the first time I actually
thought that I was been in space for
about three weeks and I woke up one
morning I'm hanging on my on the wall in
my sleeping bag and I'm checking the
messages the ground team sent up
overnight you know
send something to the printer and I
float through the module and I'm like I
work in space
sensation to adapt to an environment and
a place like that and and I I really I
enjoy it I I'm good at it I I love doing
it and it's it feels like home and
you've used your own body as a test
subject is that correct yes over the
years we've I've done lots of
Investigations looking at various
different effects on bone muscle
um you know brain everything has been
tested in the human body we tested
before flight during the flight and then
after the flight to see how the changes
are impacted is it long-term short-term
effects
and so what's been your most significant
finding or at least significant to you
well I think
the part of the reason space is a good
tool for doing research on Bones is
important for Earth obviously because
people get osteoporosis as they age and
so on in orbit we lose one percent of
bone density a month as compared to one
percent a year and what a osteoporetic
woman would lose here on Earth so it's
like 12 times the rate that we're losing
bone compared to those people and that's
and this is in healthy younger people
who
just that lack of gravity causes the
bones to get weaker
and doing research looking at new drugs
to prevent the bone loss and understand
the mechanism of why that is happening
using zero gravity as a tool to help us
speed up that process
can help us understand even more they
found for instance even just the vitamin
D levels that the FDA had approved were
not enough and so we've FDA has
increased the vitamin D levels as a
result of that NASA research and so just
there's lots of little bits and pieces
along the way that we've learned
just using our own humans as research
tools as well and you've also talked
about
when you're up there for a long duration
because otherwise muscles deteriorate I
think you've said two hours a day yeah
so we do what's called resistive
exercise because obviously you can't
lift weights in zero gravity
we do resistive exercise pulling against
a resistance or we do running on a
treadmill but you have to be harnessed
down to the treadmill with a certain
tension in order because as soon if you
tried to run you would just bounce off
the ceiling
and we use a cycle ergometer which is
pretty similar to what you have on the
ground it's just isolated and kind of
floats as as you're uh doing your
cycling so it's it's a little bit
different but we spend about two hours a
day on long duration missions and doing
exercise are there applications for
people on Earth from that Discovery do
you think or uh even for people who are
aging yeah so for aging I think and also
people who are bedridden understanding
why how and why the muscle atrophy is
occurring and how to prevent it is
really important uh uh just a
kind of as an aside research that we
found in space
there's so many Avenues of research I
feel like you've also talked about
tricks you've played on each other in
space you managed to have some fun up
there is there a story that stands out
absolutely oh well you know the the kind
of the standard trick that you play on
the new guy that shows up
is to ask them to throw you something
because in zero gravity your mind is
coming up from Earth your mind is
putting an arc on it
as you throw something when you throw a
ball here on Earth it's it's got an arc
on it because you have to compensate for
gravity in order to get it where you
want it to be
in space everybody will put an arc on it
without even knowing thinking about it
and it'll hit the ceiling so it takes a
while to learn that you just pass things
you know straight at somebody then when
I came back to Earth I figured out well
you know the Trick's on me or the jokes
on me because I tried to throw a tissue
in a trash can and it dropped right at
my feet and I'm like oh gotta put that
Arc back on there
yeah
that's the sillier side but on a more
philosophical level I've heard
astronauts talk about the overview
effect the effect of seeing the Earth in
its totality
and how that changes your perspective or
how it can potentially change your
perspective so I wanted to ask you how
has being above the Earth looking at it
as a globe
one one piece of the solar system
changed the way you think about the
world it's uh it's really impressive
it's hard to describe but I'm going to
try the seeing the Earth from above to
me is most importantly changes your
perspective because you see this whole
planet and you know as you grow up you
know you're at your home is your
community your house your family and
then it expands as you grow a little bit
further and you know then I started
traveling and you know became the whole
United States and then I started
traveling to Russia and then it became
when I got to the United States was home
and and as you leave the planet
home is Earth
the whole thing
just because you have this perspective
of it from a distance so that
perspective is is very important I think
to my sense of where we are and who who
we are in this universe you look out you
see thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of stars and you
realize that's just our little universe
and that our little Galaxy
and that there are billions and billions
of galaxies out there and it's this
whole sense of perspective this Earth is
so important to us I like to think of it
as spaceship earth
because you're out in this nothingness
and we have to protect it and take care
of it and maybe we should take care of
each other too on spaceship earth
because
there's just so much out there and that
sense of perspective is is really
important to me as you talk about ways
perspectives can change from space I
think about some of the conflict we have
among humans and I know space travel has
kind of been called the playground for
the rich or private space travel has
been called a playground for the rich
but do you think there could be a
benefit in really democratizing access
and one day getting more regular people
up in space Oh I absolutely believe that
expanding that access to Space is really
important but if you think about you
know our commercial status now and back
when we were trying to get commercial
status on airlines
you know it it started off being just
the rich that were involved and we are
trying you know we are in that process
of you know developing something that is
going to open up and expand access to
more and more people and so I'm very
excited about that goal for Axiom space
to expand access
when you talk about expanding access
there's also on the astronaut side of
things the engineering the science
careers that can lead to it what's your
grade on how we're doing and getting
underrepresented people into space or
into these careers
well I I think you know we have to keep
trying as long as we're talking about it
we're not there yet
it's important for us to expand and open
up and show people just like I was shown
when I graduated from high school
that women could be in part of space I
think it's important that we have as
many people have access to space as
possible from all over the globe so that
all the children are dreaming
you've been on the selection committee
for NASA what have you learned being on
that selection committee for people
watching and who want to get to that
level I think what do they need to do
yeah so any field in science math
engineering art all those fields if
you're an expert in them and you're
really good at it you have an
opportunity to open up an opportunity in
space
um but for me and what I always remind
people young people you have to not be
afraid of failure you have to try and
expand beyond your what you think you
can do if you only do what you know you
can succeed at
then you're never going to find out what
you really can do and I wanted to be an
astronaut but I never knew I could be
you know a commander on the ISS I never
knew that I could be the chief astronaut
at Nasa and all those things were a part
of me doing and taking those
opportunities that I wasn't sure I would
succeed at but I learned from them and I
took those those teachings
to heart and became qualified then to
become a better leader the next time I
went stepped out and challenged myself
to do more and now having been the first
female commander of a private space
flight how does the private commanding
compared to the other types of
leadership you've been able to exhibit
in this space well the the similarity is
you know you're still responsible for
the health and safety of the crew and
the vehicle and the and then the overall
success of the mission and so that those
objectives as in my role as Commander
are all the same the things that are
different are our objectives for you
know developing a program a mission for
each of the individuals and at the same
time from my my personal goal was to
develop a team that was very much
integrated and supportive of the team
Mission as well what's next is the moon
next for you or Mars or Beyond I'm ready
to sign up for any of those options
we're talking for the 50 or 50
Innovation list what Innovation do you
want to see either from your own
scientific work or from Axiom in the
next one five or ten years
of in the five to ten year time frame I
think we can definitely be developing uh
medical pharmaceutical therapies uh
using space as a tool to help us get
there I I think that's an easy ask
um what I really want to see happen
though is you know sustainable habitats
on the lunar surface space stations
around the moon
and then habitation on the Martian
surface as well and that's probably a
few more years out at me on that that
sounds like science fiction doesn't it
habitat on mars or from your perspective
it's totally possible it's absolutely
possible and it will take Innovation
we've got to come up with new innovative
ways to protect the human body from the
radiation the higher radiation levels
maybe that some of that is just
developing faster engines to get us from
place to place but we've also got to
build habitats maybe Subterranean
or using the regolith the soil of the
lunar surface or the Martian surface and
actually 3D printing using the regolith
to make your habitats and have an
expandable inflatable inside
uh to
live from I I think there's lots of
innovative ways that we can come up with
Solutions and I've heard many young
people
Innovative folks that have ideas about
how we could do these and I'd love to
see all of that happen
when you were in your 20s and 30s did
you ever imagine your career over 50 and
if so what did you think it would be and
how does the reality compare
honestly in my 20s and 30s I probably
didn't think about being 50. I think
that's probably very common I mean I
didn't fly in space until I was 42. and
um I I don't know I think that it's very
special to have had the opportunity to
get to space but to the whole path along
the way has been so important to me
so when I was young I I don't know that
I would have thought of myself
as 50 and what would I be doing after
50. at the time I became an astronaut
even at the age of 35
I there weren't astronauts that were
much over 60. and so you know times are
changing
just going up in space do you feel the
effects on your body differently now
than when you were 42.
um it's probably a little longer to
recover from you know it's hard to tell
though from my first mission was only
six months long in the the longest when
I was 57.
um was
um nine and a half months and so it's
different duration but it was a longer
harder to recover from that one I don't
know if it was an age thing or a
duration thing well we asked people as
part of this package is being over 50 an
advantage or a disadvantage in your line
of work and if so why
so for me now it's a absolutely an
advantage I'm using my expertise to help
other folks get the most out of their
opportunity to be in space whether
that's to develop scientific experiments
or to outreach for young people
I'm using that expertise I'm also using
my expertise to help the young Engineers
who are designing the next space station
Axiom space station and that's really
exciting to me to be a part of that and
to be able to use all those hours and
days in space
as a tool for to help other one folks
step over and bypass some of the hard
hard technology steps you're using your
technical expertise to advise
when you think about your life
experience what would you tell women in
their 20s and 30s who are watching this
and feeling like they have to cram in
all their professional and personal
success before 50 even before 30.
well I think it's not necessary
obviously as much as I wanted to be an
astronaut before I was 30. I was a much
better astronaut
getting in later having more life
experience and using learning from all
those lessons along the way that made me
a much better
astronaut made me more qualified for
more opportunities
and so I I would I would tell people you
know use every Avenue as a learning
experience and challenge yourself to
live outside what's comfortable so that
you really can find out what you're
capable of because it's so much more
than you might even dream of
[Music]
oh
foreign